now trying to figure out what's up with
the afc west as the
2020 offseason reaches full bloom
let's begin with the team from the west
that made it back to the super bowl for
the second straight year but this time
around
did not win it and the real question is
how much will that hang over the 2021
chiefs will it be a motivating factor is
it a humbling factor do
they you know go back to the lab do you
question everything that you're doing
i think all the above is possible as
well it does motivate you but it does
get you to take a step back and say we
got a little too complacent
are there things we need to address how
do we avoid the outcome
that we just experienced two and a half
weeks ago no question
i mean they certainly got a tinker with
the formula a little bit they got
exposed with what we saw in the super
bowl again
now you know i don't know if i want to
say it exposed
but certainly you know an element of
versatility within their offense
needs to be added and we've talked about
this a lot you know first off we
i think we were both shocked by the plan
of attack that kansas city chase had
against tampa bay
there was no plan b and it seemed like
they played a game that they totally
expected to be played
like it was in week 12 which is going to
be a lot of you know defensive looks
that were gonna let mahomes throw bombs
down the field those are the plays they
called in the super bowl
make no sense especially with a a less
than average offensive line
but like just to start the conversation
off
i do think hey listen they're going to
play through their offense we know that
that's not going to change they're going
all in on offense
but they got to make a decision about
how they want to play
offense they do they can't continue just
to go shotgun
and we're going to let mahomes float
around and make
unbelievable plays listen they almost
lost the super bowl before this
because it was a little like that i mean
it was 20 to 10 with six minutes left
now they lost this one in a bad fashion
and i do think that's a little bit
because
there's got to be another element that
they bring
and whether that's we want to talk or or
strengthen our offensive line and be
maybe a little more balanced
and then maybe use the play-action pass
from underneath center to let my homes
throw deep passes or something like that
or the other avenue i would say mike is
they got to get a route runner on their
team that would be the other thing i
would say
they need a julian edelman type okay
there goes michael hartman there goes
you know tyree kill they need a guy that
can go underneath
and work people to death linebackers
safeties
isn't that kelsey though it is kelsey
but you need more you need more than
just one guy to do that especially if
your team is going to be
based around the offense and that's
going to be all about that pressure
because if they take kelsey away okay
you're going to be able to play certain
defenses and teams and schemes they're
gonna go
okay we got enough players here to kind
of play zone our linebacker is pretty
good
like tampa bay and we'll make life hard
on you
but if they have another guy underneath
that element along with
more offensive plays like that
i just think that you know they got to
make a decision on how they want to
approach the offensive side of the ball
that would be one of the first things i
would say with kansas city
well and we've we've seen andy reid as a
head coach in the nfl long enough to
know that the run game is not going to
be used excessively by him
right you throw in the fact that you've
got one of the best quarterbacks in the
history of the game
it's tempting to let him go do his thing
but we've seen the
effort to try to bump up the running
game clyde edwards a lair and right out
of the gates last year week one against
the texans thursday night football on
nbc
he had over 100 rushing yards they just
don't stick with it you know they wanted
adrian peterson after he was cut by
washington
peterson wanted to sign right away for
week one the chiefs wanted to wait until
after that
thursday game so peterson said no to the
chiefs it seems like they're trying
le'veon bell even though he's more of a
dual threat guy they're trying
to beef up the running game they just
don't commit to it and
you know this reminds me of what
happened with the steelers and the
explanations that were provided
by people like jerome bettis he was
speaking to ed bouchet of the athletic
during the season and he said look the
commitment to the run isn't something
that just pops up out of the blue
right it's baked into the team from
training camp on
you don't just all of a sudden say we're
gonna run the ball more it's an attitude
of the offensive lineman think about it
it's two very different jobs pass
blocking and run blocking it
it's two mentalities it's attack versus
defend
when you're past blocking you're keeping
the attackers from getting to the
quarterback when you're on blocking
you're trying to put guys on their ass
it's two different mindsets they have to
decide
early on what they're going to be and
once you make that choice in july in
august
it's impossible to change it no exactly
right and you know first off i'll i'll
piggyback over what you said i
i you know you're right andy reid i
don't think it's in his dna to be
balanced and do that i don't think
that's really
you know realistic to think at this
point i don't think he's gonna change
at least i don't expect him to uh but
but it is jerome bettis is exactly right
we said that about pittsburgh at the end
of the year too like you can't just go
okay now we're gonna run the football
that's not gonna work
there's no way now i i think that
within the clyde edwards hilaire thing
and this is where
okay we got a running back like that you
got travis kelsey as you mentioned
you know to me the element they need to
get in they need to
go watch sean payton and how they get
the ball to alvin kamara
out of the backfield in the pass game
again that will add to that short
passing game all the ways brady you know
and james white and dion lewis used to
carve everybody up in the short passing
game that way too there has to be that
part of
their offense that has to grow and
expand in a big time way
because i just i you can't just think
you're gonna just keep
dialing up hey we're gonna throw the
ball down the field
and bombs away and do that against the
elite
teams and football every week in the
playoffs
and we've seen two just to add to that
fact
as awesome as mahomes is you know in
playoff football
he he hasn't thrown up a bunch of 300
yard games
and things like that and i think that's
of course because you're playing
defenses how
hey we're smart we're in the playoffs we
know how you play
and they can take away so many of those
elements of that deep passing game and
that's to me where
you know one of the first things they
got to figure out you know
like i said a guy that can really
work underneath with kelsey clyde
edwards hilaire and then he got hardman
and
hardman and tyree kill on the outside to
scare people to death down the field
put the graphic back up please to the
receiving leaders it is too skewed
toward kelsey and hill
yes we got to see more people that's
what i mean
whether it's hard man if sammy watkins
stays and who knows at this point i
think it's up in the air but
i don't know that there's going to be a
big contract out there for him with no
team demarcus robinson whoever else it
is byron pringle's a guy that flashes
from time to time but it can't just be
kelsey and hill
it can't be because if one of those guys
gets hurt you're screwed
right and if like we saw in the super
bowl
where you play certain defenses tyree
kill becomes like a non
you know factor in the football game and
then it just becomes
whoa i mean i hope kelsey can get open
all game long against devon white and
levante david and do that
and i think it's just too much to ask
there it really is you're right there's
got to be
more spread wealth you know and that's
you know again i think you look at a lot
of the the really great offenses through
time
you know and i just right away go to
peyton manning and the colts and brady
they made you think about more than two
guys in their attack now they might know
about
had all household names but oh
you know you're taking away edelman and
gronk okay well we got
amendola and james white you're not
gonna just get off the hook we're not
going to be like oh
you took away edelman and gronk we're
screwed the game's over
no they had a part of their offense to
go okay here goes plan b and plan c
unlock these guys and we're going to run
these plays for them that to me is one
of the biggest elements that misses from
there
missing from their offense and i
certainly you know would like to see
groan because they are going to play
through their offense we know that
you make a great point there and i'm
looking at the stats now from the
greatest show-offs on turf in 1999 i
mean you had marshall falk isaac bruce
tory hulk right ozzie keem right there
there was
there was just and you got yet and
you need more than two bottom line right
and and
with a quarterback like patrick mahomes
it shouldn't be that hard to cultivate
more than two and maybe he does lean a
little bit too much and maybe the
the play callers are leaning a little
too much toward getting the ball to
tyree kill and travis kelsey
but but they do need to diversify and
they do need to find a way
to run the ball more effectively maybe
that needs to be the priority they
perfected the passing game
going to training camp with this renewed
attitude of we're gonna we're gonna run
block and we're gonna we're gonna go
hard and we're gonna commit to running
the ball
and maybe we don't need to average 36
points per game
uh maybe maybe we can be as effective
with fewer points but you know holding
the ball a little bit longer keeping the
other offense off the field because so
many teams now are trying to outscore
the kansas city chiefs i i hey hey
their formula has delivered two straight
super bowl appearances that's right
but i i think they'd prefer two straight
super bowl wins
the question is what do they have to do
to regroup and get over the hump the
next time
that they're in a super bowl which could
be as soon as this year and and i think
it's fair to say
you've got to do more offensively and if
you can run the ball more that would be
great and also
they need to use some of that cap space
to have better backups you can't have
your two top tackles go down
and often have guys who who step in who
who aren't good enough you need veterans
and this may be the year to do it
if veterans are available if they get
cut by their teams or they don't get
signed up in free agency
you do a one-year deal with some of
these better players who come in and
provide that
support in the event that there are
injuries again down the street i think
that would be
if you asked me number two thing it'd be
it would be what you just said there i
think you're spot on it would be
okay offensive line has got to improve a
little bit and even despite the injuries
listen i know
mitchell schwartz back he's one of the
best right tackles in football fischer
at left tackle really damn good
those at middle three though i mean even
when healthy
it's not a special group you know uh
duvernay tardif maybe he comes back
hopefully
that'll certainly help them um but i do
think if you're gonna play
the style of football whether what
either one we're talking about we're
gonna run the ball board like you're
talking about or
we're gonna grow the passing offense and
be more effective that way
then that certainly has to be looked at
about that interior three i mean
they they got dominated up there so
much throughout the year and
we we just kind of go ah not a big deal
because 15 is magical and there's just
so many games during the year like we
talked about mike where
we would be here on a tuesday and a
wednesday and you'd go you know you
watched the film what do you think and
i'd go
i just can't believe how much pressure
mahomes was under
watching the game on sunday i didn't
really realize it because he always
makes a play and throws a 15-yard laser
and we just move on
but constantly under duress and that has
to change too
if you want to play that style of
football that they're playing
yeah there's a there's a temptation
to just rely on patrick mahomes to to
save your butt
every week because he has in a
relatively short period of time
a long resume of saving the chief's
butts by
finding ways to make things happen to
the point where that becomes your crutch
that becomes your your play in madden
that you always
use that always works and in real world
nfl
it's just let patrick mahomes figure
something out and and uh
that works until it doesn't and it
didn't on super bowl sunday against the
buccaneers and you need a little bit
more
then you you know that moms when you
rely on him to get it done is going to
get it done that just can't be the plan
week in and week out driving and drive
out you need to have more than that it
can't be
mahomes run around until kelsey or he'll
get open and if all else fails run the
ball to daylight right there's got to be
more than that yeah they got to help him
right yeah i mean he's
he's as gifted as we've ever seen right
i mean there's no doubt about that
he's got a chance to be the greatest
player i've ever seen in my life at the
quarterback he really is
but he's not going to just overcome the
great defenses in football by himself
all the time that is not possible it
really isn't so
that has to be talked about and then hey
you want to hit their defense real quick
i mean just as
we get into this because i know we're
going to talk about the raiders too yeah
the defense you know and here's free
agents i would be shocked if sammy
watkins is back unless he takes a really
really team friendly deal
you know demarcus robinson i don't know
where that goes either
i don't think he really fits the mole i
you know he's
he's he's not an underneath route runner
anything like that so i don't know where
that goes
but you know you see bashad breeland
free agent
hey he's a pretty good player i'm not
saying he's a shut down island corner
but he is a good player
other than that you know sorensen's done
a lot of good jobs for them
i'll be interested to see what they
offer and try to get them back they're
key parts
but i think the rest of those guys on
that list i don't think that
kansas city is going to bend over
backwards trying to get deals done with
you know the majority of these guys we
see here on this graphic
uh they got to improve their secondary a
little bit certainly at the corner
position they could probably maybe help
out a little bit but man
they're an offensive football team spags
does a great job of what he has
and he covers up some of the
deficiencies he has on the defensive
side of the ball
with his great coaching i think and
and these elite teams this is a great
opportunity to go out
and buy veterans who will be available
as they're cut by other teams
and as they don't get big deals
elsewhere that's when
as things settle the the great teams
that can offer a chance at a super bowl
championship
that's the difference that's the factor
that gets some of these guys to come in
on one year deals and you put together a
little mini super team to try to get
back to the super bowl for a third
straight
rusher mike i'll say that too that's
probably absolutely yeah
absolutely and and uh we saw we saw the
value of having
two guys who can get around the edge in
the tampa bay buccaneers and what they
were able to do with shaq barrett and
jpp
yeah they got frank clark they've got
chris jones disrupting up the middle
get a guy on the other edge and that
defense becomes a lot better
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports